[Music]
and now at the center of the zero
experience hunter biden
scandal and biden let's see foreign
syndicate issue
well is hunter biden's laptop which
reportedly contains
well a lot of disturbing material now
computer repair shop owner john paul
mack
isaac he turned the laptop over to the
fbi in december of 2019
after hunter failed to retrieve it from
his store 90 days later and after facing
endless slander
and death threats he even closed down a
shop for a while and went out of town
he's now come forward to tell his side
of the story john paul joins us for an
exclusive interview john paul sir
thank you for being with us thank you
evening sean
let's get into the document side of it
so there were would it be a fair
statement to say
that what you saw concerns you
uh that you desperately wanted to get
this out of your shop as you said
correct so so on both fronts there i
just want to make
other things let me let me go through
the the timeline with you if i may
because you you handed this over to the
fbi
they finally took possession of it
december 9 2019. tell us what happened
uh they came to the shop originally they
were planning to make a forensic copy of
the drive they couldn't guarantee that
they could take the
uh the equipment away from me uh
so when they showed up and they handed
me a subpoena requesting the drive the
paperwork and the laptop
i was overjoyed that they were gonna
basically meet my demands if you will i
wanted it out of my shop and i wanted
some kind of paper trail some level of
protection from the fbi
so i was pretty happy that they took it
a couple things happened
during that exchange a couple things
were said that kind of again threw up
some red flags with the fbi
just how they wanted me to handle it if
he could should come looking for it how
to contact them how to
stall that whoever's looking for it so
they could make arrangements to have the
equipment returned to me uh it did kind
of uh
it uh i was concerned
in so december 19 to remind everybody
because impeachment on the issue of
ukraine took place with president trump
in january
of 2020 and i guess my question is
what you saw in terms of documents did
that seem
relevant to you to the debate that was
explained um
well i had seen uh what would
again i'm i'm not an investigative
journalist it's not my day job
uh when i was fixing max but i saw some
pretty compelling documents that uh
definitely showed a pay-for-play
scheme going on between hunter biden
and his you know his business dealings
in ukraine
joe biden claimed that he didn't know
anything about his son's business
dealing will the documents
that you saw contradict that
incontrovertibly and
contradict that
yeah i i think uh there was a lot of
coordination
you know i saw a couple emails coming
directly out of the white house to
members of barisma staff that
you know including the vice president's
schedule
any discussions that were going on about
ukraine and policies with ukraine
were being sent directly to vadim who's
the number two at prisma
knowing what you know that was on it
knowing that you followed the proper
chain of command
knowing that you were glad to finally
get it out of your possession but yet it
was the smartest thing you ever did in
handing it over
for your own benefit and safety and you
wondered why was it not
admitted as evidence as impeachment
now is the evidence that compelling that
it was that
relevant i assume my interpretation is
that you saw a flagrant double standard
existed am i right in my interpretation
well what i saw was uh
you know uh two two young men that were
definitely capitalizing off of uh
at least one of their father's positions
to
uh drum up more value in
in their efforts to to get more money
and it was
it was definitely a pay-for-play scheme
that
i again i got my law degree at rodeo
clown school so i'm not
that brian's better at the the legal
stuff but the uh
it looked like this would be something
that you would want to have a
conversation with to another foreign
leader
about because this was a lot of money
that was exchanging hands like a lot of
money
and you search you still have a copy of
the hard drive is that correct
correct um would you be willing to share
it with me
i would love it i'd have to talk to my
attorney about that
you'll consider you'll take it under
consideration
yeah i i i have a very good attorney
and he's not looking for for myself
listen
uh sir i i all i've read about you and
all i've heard that you said
you've been put in a horrible position i
argue unfairly so and
you know you just saw something you said
something we ask people all the time
see something say something and you did
and
it's it should not have happened to you
this way is your business doing better
now are you getting
harassed less are you able to keep the
doors open
well i'm getting harassed a lot less
since i had to disconnect the phone in
the email server
the business has been closed since
november 2nd for my safety i had to get
out of town about that time i just
didn't know
the the hostility in my area was getting
to the point where i didn't want to
incite any anger so i thought it was
best that i just closed the business and
then get out of town
thank you for sharing sir it's an
important story you did do the right
thing you can't you
you're i think based on everything you
said to me and what
people have told me they believe is on
it that um
that what you did is important honorable
and
i hope all the harassment of you stops
and you continue
you know your life hopefully in
anonymity and peace thank you sir
well thank you sir thanks for your time
and letting me uh tell my story
we taped this just before the show
tomorrow part two the majority of the
interview
talks about video content it's shocking
here's a preview i saw material of a
very personal
i don't want to obviously go into it i
don't feel comfortable about talking
about
the the personal stuff the bigger part
of that interview part two tomorrow
news that hasn't broken before more
hannity after this